trump
gets interviewed by laura trump yeah
okay which it looks like
he's already fired up which it looks
like it was done at mar-a-lago
okay where the interview is being done
by his daughter-in-law
facebook scrubs donald trump's interview
with laura trump cites indefinite
ban keep going up for doing this can you
go higher to see what else they're
saying the other way go lower
so your facebook took down a video of
donald trump conducted by donald trump
uh for her show the right view i like
that name the right instead of the view
facebook spokesman andy stone said that
the video was not permitted on facebook
and instagram because of the former
president's
indefinite suspension after the deadly
capital right on tuesday laura trump
posted on instagram big show tonight
i will be joined by president donald
trump on the right view laura trump
who's married to eric trum received an
email from facebook and the content the
voice advice
voice of former president trump is not
currently allowed on our platform
including new posts with president trump
speaking facebook warned
that any future post would be removed
resulting in additional limitations on
account that posted
laura trump then posted the uh video
interview on the social network rumble
facebook suspended on drunken so what
are your thoughts about this i think the
censorship in the media especially
social media but all the media
is absolutely anti-first amendment it is
not america
and it is incredibly dangerous i mean
nothing they said in that interview is
dangerous
um i i just can't i just can't believe
we're living in
this is our country we're living in
right now and it's and what's amazing is
the left was the
they were the ones back in the 60s and
all the free speech and
right to assemble and they were doing
all this you know peaceful protests and
all this other stuff
they were the ones driving you know the
the uh putting free speech out there as
a uh
um out in the forefront and they were
the ones they were they were the free
speech party if you will not that the
republicans
or the right was it was against free
speech but i mean it is gone today it is
unbelievable i mean
you can't say anything if you say the
wrong thing
you run the risk of being canceled and
it's it's crazy i mean here's a man that
a lot of people want to hear what he has
to say
nothing he said in that interview is
dangerous but because
some arbiter of truth
facebook twitter whatever decides that
they
whatever he's saying doesn't fit their
left-wing narrative they're going to
literally silence somebody it's insane
absolutely insane
can't believe this is going on in
america you know it's crazy like you
remember the first big name
that got banned on social media was who
alex jones it happened within a 24-hour
window where he was shut down on
facebook twitter instagram youtube they
took down
info awards they took down all these
other things and then they took down
paypal and
they shut them down right but when he
gets interviewed
they allow his interviews to stay on so
when alex jones goes on rogan or he did
an interview with us on 9 11 like six
years ago or four years ago he stayed on
it was literally a week after he got
banned we interviewed him
his interview stayed on they haven't
taken it down yet why
why are you taking down an interview of
president
trump even bernie sanders came out did
you hear what bernie sanders said last
week about
yeah he thinks it's dangerous because
you never know who it's going to be next
he says look i don't like
anything about trump what he does he's a
xenophobe he's this he's a womanizer
he said all this stuff so don't get me
wrong all of that stuff i still believe
in a guy
but it's i don't support at all to
silence the former president he says i
don't think that's good for our society
even a socialist bernie sanders defended
trump and facebook takes this position
what are your thoughts
so i'm going to shock you guys and i'm
going to shock our audience here we go
and i'm actually going to come out and
tell
you that i agree with our friend byron i
think it's a
um very dangerous position where
um these big tech companies facebook
instagram you know twitter all
all this can just say no you're gone
you've been you're canceled and
obviously they've been looking for any
excuse
to get rid of trump for years even
though obviously the
media network's ratings have been sky
high over the last five years covering
trump and all the nonsense that comes
along
with the trump reality presidency oh
they're going to miss him in their
pocketbook
that's true but um you know
clearly i'm not a fan of trump but um do
i think that the freaking
president ex-president united states
should just be
permanently banned from being
interviewed no i think that's a very
slippery slope obviously we're talking
about the first amendment here
and i agree with bernie sanders and i
agree with byron here and i agree with
what the first amendment stands for and
i think
and this is this will go back to a
bigger story all right cool this article
got taken down
what are the chances that trump can
either run or win again in 2024
and if this is the narrative that if any
time he comes out and speaks it gets
taken down
put a fork in him right now because if
you can't get your views out there and
your perspectives out there
on twitter on facebook on youtube on
social media you got no chance bro
you got this so last point
it all comes down to the the um
insurrection or whatever you want to
call it the surge
at the capitol that was the the day that
they said dude
this guy's done and he's been banned
ever since so they were just looking for
an excuse they were looking for an
excuse that's my point but
he believed me he gave him one because
that was a disgusting situation that
happened it was a horrible situation but
it's not what the media made it out to
be it's not was not 9 11.
let's give me a break yeah i mean
obviously there were no planes flying
into buildings byron
that's a stretch there but um armed
insurrection
that's true as far as i know nobody was
found with a gun
in the capital nobody the bigger story
here is we've talked about who are the
most powerful people
in our country um the president
media company social media universities
um billionaires and who sits at the top
of that list these days i think
it's you'd be very hard to fight against
that
that big tech or social media are the
most powerful influencers in the country
i know universities are right up there
in the making sure but certainly but to
the extent that they're controlling the
content
absolutely completely just let it happen
yeah and let it be and that's
that's why there's sort of a uh there's
a there's a
pent up demand for some sort of
decentralization in
social media which is what my son is was
talking about with with uh
with that platform shout out to jake if
you're watching jake if you're listening
and watching
so i i just agreed that who's your
biggest fan just to all our
our listeners out there our fans out
there valuetainers i just agreed that
trump should be able to
be seen on yeah i think i think for me
i'm more thinking about
okay uh uh who is behind it is zuck
saying taken down is zuck afraid because
he's in silicon valley and pelosi is
going to destroy his business and
regulation so they have to take it down
is zuck trying to be loyal to who who's
he being loyal to who is he afraid of is
biden telling them taking down are they
choosing to take it down themselves
is this board tell them to take you down
someone's telling him to take you down
because i don't think it's
zuck i don't really think zuck is about
taking it down i don't believe that i
think someone
uh behind closed doors is challenging
them to take you down and
and here's what it does okay so so think
about it from this standpoint okay
does constantly silencing trump
make him stronger or does constantly
silencing trump make him more irrelevant
what does it do
i think uh there's a little bit of both
but i think it probably weighs in favor
of the latter i think it makes him
more irrelevant because nobody hears it
more irrelevant
i mean when you when you saw that biden
story that didn't get
that that was basically quashed right
before the election with the scandal
with his son new york post yeah i mean
the vast majority of americans never saw
the story it was a huge story huge
scandal i mean this anybody else this
would have been
all over the news and they literally not
only shut the story down they
they shut down the new york post they
shut down their entire twitter account
are you kidding me really i mean this is
a little bit where is that story now
though
i haven't heard anything about hunter
biden in months again
they could still fox could still be
talking about it why are they not
talking about how things work
the left and the the left is in social
media they talk about benghazi for
the guy just came out with a book
talking about his crack experience he
wrote
he's talking about his experience with
crack okay
hunter so this this is not like the he
got down to a point where he brought a
homeless guy to live with them
off the street because he couldn't get
off the addiction of drugs i mean you're
not talking about a regular thing here
but he's talking about the
silencing the story at that time wasn't
just about hunters or either is it a
joke
is it an effective strategy that's all
i'm asking is it an impressive strategy
to silence trump
it worked okay surveys have been taken a
vast majority of biden voters didn't
even know about it and if they had they
might not have voted so
zero to ten give me a percentage what
percentage chance trump's running
trump runs in 2024 60 you're saying 60
he runs yes what do you say he runs
2024.
i'm gonna do the um prices right
approach and say 61
well you're going to say he's going to
run no matter i think he's going to run
justice what do you think
that eager you think he's going to run
um
i think he'll flirt with the idea i just
don't know if he'll officially run give
us a number
i'd say i'm going to do like a 50. okay
what do you think what about you
i don't know i i'm none
i'm below 50. i'm not at the i'm not as
optimistic as you guys are i'm not as
optimistic as you guys are because
the only thing that would change my
optimism
is if he has a place where people can go
every day every hour to hear what he has
to say
if he comes up with an association the
rumor is that he will i mean shortly
buddy let me put it to you this way last
night
we had to the amount of traffic that was
going on our website we got contact
about aws and they had to help us
increase the server to be able to
maintain what we were going through the
last 24 hours
so okay so aws you you develop a social
media website that's massive your name
is donald trump
you're going to need aws aws no to you
where are you going to go
anywhere else you go they say oh if you
do business with trump you can't do
business with us
how the hell did rumble go down so if
rumble cannot stay up
you know and not rumble but parlor
cannot stay up what are they going to do
with this guy like what is the
difference so he creates a social media
you need an
you need a hosting service you need
those guys so he's got the resources to
set up his own hosting
if he wants to yeah it's it then then
then he's got the resource to set up his
own hosting service it's not as cheap as
you think it is this is not a million
dollar cost
it's not a 10 million dollar cost
hosting service is not cheap especially
if he gets the kind of traffic that we
think he's going to be getting if he
gets the kind of traffic that we think
he's going to be getting
it's not a cheap investment so now the
flip side of it comes what
if the republican party unites behind
him
to help fund him different story does he
have that kind of backing
i don't know if he does i don't know if
he does so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]